la parole est à sur roger karoutchi pour
le groupe l'est républicain
il avait la parole celui liste de
l'intérieur face au drame
nous serons là nous sont là pour avec
vous faire en sorte de poursuivre l'état
d'urgence nous serons là pour soutenir
nos forces de sécurité sur les
interpellations
nous serons là chaque fois que vous
prendrez des décisions d'expulsion nous
sont là chaque fois que vous prendrez
des décisions de fermeture
nous serons là chaque fois que vous
prendrez des décisions de déchéance de
nationalité mais aujourd'hui un autre
problème se pose dans l'esprit des
français
est-ce que la porosité de nos frontières
n'a pas favorisé permis bien des
mouvements qui sont au final des
mouvements très nuisibles à la sécurité
des français
alors vous avez déjà décidé de me
remettre en place le contrôle des
frontières
mais monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
est ce qu'il n'est pas temps de demander
à nos partenaires européens qui eux
mêmes sont frappés par les actes
terroristes
est-ce qu'il n'est pas temps de leur
demander de refaire de refonder de
réviser schengen pour faire en sorte que
les frontières ne soient plus des
passoires et que l'europe soit protégé
merci pour vous répondre la parole et à
bernard cazeneuve ulysse de l'intérieur
monsieur le sénateur karoutchi je crois
que sur ces sujets là il faut avoir une
approche extrêmement pragmatiques nous
avons établi les contrôles aux
frontières
avant que la crise terroristes ne se
déclenche pour des raisons qui tenait à
la coop 21 et nous avons mis en place
dans le cadre des contrôles aux
frontières les contrôles renforcés à
partir du moment où la crise terroriste
s'était déclenchée
est ce que il y as a risk dans le
contexte terroristes qui prévaut de voir
des individus franchir les frontières de
notre pays pour y commettre des
attentats la réponse est oui c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons procédé
à la mise en place de ce contrôle est ce
qu'il est nécessaire de modifier le code
frontière schengen pour obtenir des pays
de l'union européenne que l'on mette en
place des contrôles systématiques et
coordonnée non c'est la raison pour
laquelle je demanderai à bruxelles
vendredi prochain que ces contrôles
systématiques et coordonnées soient
mises en oeuvre dans les meilleurs
délais c'est-à-dire dans les prochains
jours si l'union européenne accepte le
principe parce que je pense que nous
devons dans le contexte de crise
terroriste si nous voulons que le
système d'information schengen donne les
résultats qu'on est en droit d'attendre
de lui mettre en place ces contrôles si
l'on veut aller plus loin
c'est à dire mettre en place des
contrôles obligatoires
alors il faut effectivement une révision
du code frontière schengen qualité la
position de la france sur ce sujet en
août 2014
nous avons demandé la mise en place de
contrôles systématiques et coordonnée il
ya beaucoup trop de temps de la part de
l'union européenne pour prendre les
bonnes décisions
et quand elle les a prises elle met des
durées emphytéotique pour les appliquer
ça suffit il faut maintenant aller à
l'essentiel et faire en sorte l'édition
soit prêt ce sera l'objet de la réunion
de vendredi et pour six contre au cern
les contrôles obligatoires ces tirs la
réforme du code frontière schengen c'est
possible mais là aussi il faut une
décision
est ce que je voulais vous dire c'est
que c'est pas la peine de faire de la
philosophie sur schengen trop schengen
de il faut mettre en place ces
dispositions très concrètes contrôles
systématiques et coordonnée et demain
contrôles obligatoires
voilà quelle est notre feuille de route
karoutchi
seule ministre de l'intérieur si tous
les ministres de l'intérieur d'europe
avaient la même position
ce serait peut-être plus simple mais ça
n'est pas le cas et tant que ça n'est
pas le cas on voit bien on grille en
macédoine et ailleurs que les frontières
extérieures de l'europe ne sont pas
protégés c'est pour ça que votre
position qui consiste à dire on ne doit
pas aller brutalement pour changer la
donne
parce que on peut faire avec non tant
que nous n'avons pas de frontières
extérieures de l'europe plus sûres
il faudra bien que la france assure et
assure elle-même sa sécurité
merci